esta accidentada carretera se ha
convertido en un nuevo frente
estratégico en la guerra de ucrania es
el único vínculo que queda con la
asediada región del donbass que aún no
ha caído en manos rusas pero está bajo
constante ataque
esta furgoneta pertenece a sergei un
minero del carbón de 60 años sobrevivió
a una noche de intensos bombardeos
mientras conducía hacia el pueblo de
solo t para rescatar a sus vecinos
aquí hay abuelas y abuelos personas con
discapacidad que se quedan de pasta
vales
hoy
hay que sacarlos si tengo que morir aquí
entonces moriré aquí pero si no seguiré
sacando a la gente niebla ya la
carretera conduce al isi chance y
severodonezk antaño dos centros
industriales que ahora conforman la
última resistencia en la región de
luhansk esta casa de visitantes que fue
alcanzada por un proyectil ruso pero
incluso cuando las fuerzas invasoras
intensifican sus ataques
natalia como muchos siguen negándose a
marcharse
mi hija está en francia y me con polonia
les contesta y me dijeron que me fuera
inmediatamente pero cómo puedo irme este
es nuestro hogar esta es nuestra tierra
pero después de tres meses bajo los
bombardeos rusos y la artillería pesada
algunos han perdido su familia amigos y
la voluntad de resistir
mi esposa murió creo que durante un
ataque
los disparos alcanzaron su cabeza
por ahora lo único que pienso de sacar a
mis hijas de aquí y tratar de recuperar
nuestras vidas
dmitro como muchos otros espera aquí en
lysychansk con la esperanza de que sean
ciertos los rumores de que los
rescatistas puedan ponerlo a él ya su
familia salvo